- On descend vers la production,
c'est là que la magie s'opère.
le succès avec ses t-shirts
aux poches colorées.
- Ta-dam!
- Il y a un an, le fondateur
sa production les vendredis.
Ses employés travaillent
32 heures, mais conservent
leur plein salaire.
On parvient à faire autantre aut
en moins de temps, mais surtout,
il trouve une solution
VENDRAME,
copropriétaire de Poches & Fils
- C'est - C'est - C'est les plu"
de ça, t'sais, de pas avoir
perdu de productivité et
d'être lentslentslentslentslents
et qui en attire d'autres.
- Charles-David a d'abord craint
impose une cadence infernale.
CHARLES-DAVID HÉBERT, directeur
des opérations, Poches & Fils
- La première stratégie,r les ts
qu'on fait dans la vie de touslt
inutiles.
- Avec un gain d'ectivité a ctis
un nouvel élan.
- Le plus dur "feeling",
c'est comment je vais faire
si j'ai pour retourner à cinq j/
semaine. Parce que maintenant,c,
le quatre jours semaine, puis
je ne reviendrai pas en arrière.
- Ce que je vois avec
la nouvelle génération,
c'est qu'ils ne négocient
plus vraiment sur les salaires,
en fait. Beaucoup, beaucoup
- Selon cet expert, la semaine
de quatre jours permet aussi
aux entreprises d'économiser
sur le long terme.
JEAN-NICOLAS REYT, prof. fac
- Certaines entreprises qui
ont un remplacemenés
de 30 à 40 % par an.
Ça veut dire qu'il faut recruter
des gens, il faut nnée,nnée,nné,
vous perdez des gens qui
avaient e
connaissances qui étaient
importantes à l'entreprise.
- J'ai elundi...
- Le chef de la technologie
chez la jeune pousjeune pousjeu,
qui conçoit des casiers
sécurisés pour la livraison
rgir sa petite équipe.
32 heures en quatre jours,
qui a convaincu
Nicolas Lupien d'accepter
un emploi un peu moins payant
de son horaire.
NICOLAS LUPIEN, chef
de la technologie, Expedibox
pas en ce moment, t'sais,
t'as ma santé mentale, ma santé
physique puis le temps que
je passe avec mes enfants.
employeurs, ça va être leur
méthode pour se distinguer.
- Mais réduire de 20 %
les heures travaillées permet-il
de gagner une productivité
les secteurs économiques?
Me MARIANNE PLAMONDON,
avocate en droit du travail
- Il semble que la semaine
de quatre jours soit un peti
les travailleurs du savoir
que les travailleu......
Le fait de ne pas opérer
une journée complète, ça a
une conséquence nén
possible.
ont une tâche manuelle
et travaillent plu
40 heures en quatre jours.
FRANCIS CAMPBELL, président,
- L'apport qui est nécessaire
à la réà la créaà la créaà la cé
est moins important.
Ces travaux-là sont
Le gain du 32 heures,
on le semoins.
- Ici aussi, les employés
sur la chaîne de production
et choisissent pour la plupart
iller de plus longues
heures. Malgré des horaires
à deux vitesses, l'expérien
- Je suis vraiment content
qu'on l'ait fait et
on ne l'a pas fait plus tôt.
- Après les PME, au tour
des grandes entreprises
d'éprouver le modèle.
Radio-Canada, Mon